bei zweien ist einer zuviel gilt auch
für kanzlerkandidaten einer fliegt raus
nur wer stur blicken sich die
kontrahenten die augen keiner will
weichen
während das publikum genervt auf stöhnt
und crooner panini ihren unheilvollen
verlauf nimmt machtkampf in der union
laschet oder silber jetzt in der phoenix
runde
[Musik]
phoenix runde
herzlich willkommen bei uns meine gäste
zunächst ihrem studio katharina
hamberger ist bei uns korrespondentin im
hauptstadtstudio des deutschlandfunks
und richard hilmer ist gründer und
geschäftsführer von policy makers
gesellschaft für politik forschung und
beratung zugeschaltet sind uns der
cdu-politiker und frühere
generalsekretär der partei ruprecht
polenz und ebenfalls von der cdu der
bundestagsabgeordnete mattern von
marschall sie vertreten im bundestag den
wahlkreis freiburg von marschall
wir sind ganz wissbegierig was da heute
nachmittag in der unionsfraktion alles
passiert ist vieles wissen wir ja
inzwischen der fraktionsvorsitzende
ralph brinkhaus hat von kameraden
schweinen gesprochen die da alles
durchstechen so dass also auch die und
journalisten außen immer genau bescheid
wussten armin laschet hat sich verwahrt
geben die herabwürdigung des
cdu-präsidiums markus söder hat auf die
guten umfragewerte verwiesen was war da
los welche stimmungsbild hat sich da
gegeben
ja also vor allen dingen muss man mal
sagen dass das glaube ich die längste
allgemeine aussprache wenn man so will
war in der unionsfraktion ich glaube das
hat ralph brinkhaus auch gesagt sie
haben sich ich glaube etwa 70
kolleginnen und kollegen der zu wort
gemeldet dass allen landesverbänden und
wir haben einen ausgesprochen
vielfältiges meinungsbild insofern
erlebt und darüber bin ich sehr dankbar
das hat der ralph brinkhaus der
fraktionsvorsitzende ja auch angekündigt
dass das erfolgen sollte und ich glaube
das ist auch ein guter beitrag um diese
kanzler der kanzlerkandidatur hoffen
guten weg zu bringen
herr problem sie können ja das was in
ihrer partei gerade passiert aus einer
gewissen distanz beobachten zerlegt sich
die union gerade wenn man die letzten
tage und wochen sich ansieht das denke
ich nicht aber es wird sicherlich zeit
dass jetzt eine entscheidung getroffen
wird
die aufgabe ist eigentlich ganz einfach
zwei parteien müssen sich auf einen
kanzlerkandidaten einigen
es kandidieren die beiden
parteivorsitzenden beide sind
ministerpräsidenten und jetzt kommt
etwas erschwerend dazu was wir im
augenblick auch spüren
es gibt kein festgelegtes schriftlich
festgelegtes verfahren die in einem
solchen wettbewerb entschieden werden
kann
darauf müssen sich die parteien
verständigen und ich hoffe dass das
jetzt erstmal den beiden kandidaten
gelingt und wenn nicht dann mit hilfe
der beiden parteien eine einigung bereit
frommberger die frage ist ja wie konnte
es eigentlich so weit kommen dass sie
jetzt gerade erleben innerhalb der union
das hätte man vor wenigen wochen noch
gar nicht für möglich gehalten
fehlt in cdu und csu oder kompass man ja
also das hat sich ja zumindest schon
angedeutet dass das ist er
möglicherweise zu einem machtkampf
kommen könnte markus söder hat sich nie
letzten wochen für oder der gegner
ausgesprochen wobei antreten würde
darüber das nicht tun wird bei armin
laschet war das eigentlich immer klar er
hat das nie offen gesagt aber er kann
als cdu vorsitzender eigentlich gar
nicht anders als irgendwann zu sagen ich
möchte kanzlerkandidat werden und man
hat offenbar verpasst sich zumindest auf
irgendein verfahren zu einigen
frühzeitig man miteinander zu sprechen
und dann lief das plötzlich auf diesen
punkt zu wo dann beide gesagt haben ich
will und der andere auch gesagt hat ich
will und man irgendwie nicht mehr
rausgekommen ist aus dieser situation
also es hat dann keiner von beiden
zurückgezogen
auch nicht am montag nachdem die
cdu-gremien ja zumindest sich armin
laschet ausgesprochen haben was
eigentlich schon finde ich ein sehr
eindeutiges votum ist hat markus söder
trotzdem eben auf die umfragen geschaut
und hat gesagt ich mache weiter ich
schaue jetzt ich muss in die partei
hinein horchen und muss weiter schauen
also ich glaube das ist nicht so
geordnet war gelaufen wie man sich das
auch luis robles ins unglück gerauscht
so ein bisschen kann man das so sehen
also zumindest glaube ich hätte die
partei zumindest die cdu auch die csu
immer früher schauen müssen wie können
wir das in eine geordnetes verfahren
bringen so dass es erst gar nicht so
weit kommt man hat ja jetzt auch kein
geordnetes verfahren herr polenz
angesprochen es gibt kein wirkliches
kriterium
keine gremien die das am ende
entscheiden also am samstag war erstmals
klar es gibt zwei kandidaten aber wie es
dann weitergeht naja ist jetzt auch noch
keinen klar umfragen das sind ja nicht
alles aber ohne umfragen ist alles
nichts
der bayerische ministerpräsident hat
heute zum wiederholten mal auf seine
guten umfrageergebnisse kind wiesen auf
die stimmung die zu seinen gunsten sich
neigt im land wie verfestigt ist denn
sind denn diese zahlen diese zu zahlen
gerundet umfrageergebnisse in bezug auf
söder kann er davon ausgehen dass das
noch länger anhält dass er damit in den
bundestagswahlkampf bis zur
bundestagswahl kommt oder könnte sich
das auch schnell wieder ändern also
sicherlich nicht die berühmte
momentaufnahme sondern beide kandidaten
haben ja ausreichend gelegenheit gehabt
sich hier zu präsentieren der
bevölkerung im eigenen land aber dann
auch bundesweit während der korona krise
waren sie ja sehr präsent ein jahr und
in diesem jahr wurden eine ganze reihe
von umfragen durchgeführt auch zu dem
thema wer ist denn der bessere kanzler
kandidat auch im vergleich zu den
anderen kandidaten der anderen parteien
und das ergebnis war immer ich immer das
gleiche söder lag mehr oder weniger
deutlich vor laschet auch von den
übrigen kandidaten und das
problematische aus der sicht von laschet
ist sicherlich dass sich diese
diskrepanz zwischen den beiden mit der
zeit noch vergrößerte und zuletzt gab es
sogar eine umfrage in
nordrhein-westfalen und infratest dimap
die die stimmung im lande im eigenen
lande von laschet noch mal präsentierte
und das ergibt es war schon sehr
problematisch denn er hat die hälfte der
zustimmung die hälfte der unterstützung
der wähler verloren
die cdu stürzte ab das ist natürlich
wirklich ein problematischer start in
die heiße phase des wahlkampfs insofern
ging er schon auch belastet in diese
auseinandersetzung und söder hat das
sicherlich auch gespürt und er wollte es
würde ich jetzt mal annehmen
schon seit längerem und verweist dann
sicherlich zu recht auf die tatsache
das eben der kandidat die parteien
letztlich von den wählern von den
bürgern und bürgerinnen bestimmt werden
und das spiel natürlich die umfragen
wenn sie so stabil sind über mehrere
monate fast ein jahr jetzt das spielt
natürlich schon eine gewisse rolle also
aus sicht von laschet schlechtes timing
aus sicht von soda was die umfragen
angeht gutes timing abholen von
marschall es kein geheimnis abholen sie
präferieren den cdu-vorsitzenden mit
laschet auch als kanzlerkandidaten und
herr von marshall sie den bayerischen
ministerpräsidenten polens was spricht
denn für armin laschet in dieser
auseinandersetzung dass er jetzt
möglicherweise am freitag das würde ja
heute mal wieder als zeitkorridor
angedeutet möglicherweise am freitag zum
kanzlerkandidaten ausgerufen wird
ich würde gern zunächst noch eine
bemerkung zu den umfragen machen
sie sind alle gemacht worden während der
pandemie während der fokus der
bevölkerung ganz außerordentlich stark
auf den gesundheitlichen umgang mit
corona dem impf temporär cetera et
cetera gerichtet ist ich denke wir
können davon ausgehen dass bis zum
sommer dieser teil der pandemie
überwunden ist und der dann vor der
frage stehen und das wird dann auch in
den fokus der wählerinnen und wähler
rücken
wie geht es denn jetzt weiter mit der
wirtschaft mit sozialer gerechtigkeit
mit dem bildungswesen mit der
digitalisierung mit der modernisierung
von deutschland und ich denke dann
werden auch die karten bei
meinungsumfragen noch einmal neu
gemischt das habe ich auch ein bisschen
als warnung an meine partei weil eben
auch die umfragen etwa von der spd oder
den grünen kandidaten da durchaus auch
noch sich erinnern können zum zweiten
armin laschet hat sich als jemand
erwiesen der sehr stetig in seinen
politischen grundorientierung ist und
das löst normalerweise auch vertrauen
ein also auch in der krise wackelt er
nicht er hat bei der eurokrise weiter
pro europa rotiert er hat sich in der
flüchtlingskrise pro humanität gegen
alle widerstände ausgesprochen und er
steht auch pro zusammenhalt mit den
eingewanderten und das sind
für deutschland wie ich finde wichtige
themen und die letzter satz die
unionsspitze also der bundesvorstand hat
sich am sonntag in kenntnis auch der
momentan umfragen mit breiter mehrheit
zur armin laschet ausgesprochen er von
marshall was spricht für den bayerischen
ministerpräsidenten als den zukünftigen
kanzlerkandidaten der union für die
bundestagswahl
ich würde vielleicht vorab sagen also
bei allen unterschiedlichen auffassungen
wie heute in der fraktion deutlich
geworden sind ist der gemeinsame wille
denjenigen zu unterstützen der
kanzlerkandidat wird in der
gesamtfraktion groß was spricht für
markus söder für markus söder spricht
nicht nur der seit monaten andauernde
hohe zustimmungswerte in allen teilen
der bevölkerung kann man sagen auch über
die cdu die csu hinaus sondern und da
bin ich fest überzeugt dass das der
entscheidende punkt ist für markus söder
spricht sein kampfgeist spricht seine
entschiedenheit und spricht sein wille
zum sieg und für unser abgeordnete ja
letzten endes diesen wahlkampf vor ort
führen und führen müssen und dürfen ist
es natürlich ungeheuer wichtig dass auch
ihre ganzen mitstreiterinnen und
mitstreiter aus den ortsverbänden aus
der basis der partei mitmachen und sie
machen dann umso mehr mit wenn sie sehen
der vorne steht jemand dran der
engagiert sich der motiviert auch uns
und der bringt uns einfach zusammen in
einen guten geist in eine gute
motivationslage bis zum schlussendlich
wahltag am 26 september und ich habe
auch sehr vielen ortsverbänden und von
vielen bürgern also keineswegs nur
parteimitgliedern unmittelbaren nach
nach meiner einlassung dass sich markus
söder bevorzugen würde auch zurück
gemeldet bekommen ja das ist der
richtige mann mit dem können wir
erfolgreich zur bundestagswahl ziehen
frauenberger was muss eigentlich ein
bundeskanzler nach der bundestagswahl
vor allen dingen mitbringen er das
persönliche profil eines markus söder
der sehr selbstbewusst auftritt manchmal
etwas breitbeinig machtbewusst weiß
zumindest erweckt er den eindruck weiß
was er will oder auf der anderen seite
jemand der eher wie armin laschet
integrationsfähig ist zusammenführen
kann ausgleichen
das gilt ja nicht nur für die eigene
partei oder die fraktionsgemeinschaft
das gilt ja auch für möglicherweise
ziemlich schwierige koalitionspartner
was ist da wichtiger welches prof
ich glaube das lässt sich stand heute
noch gar nicht so sagen also wir wissen
nicht wie diese schon mal wieder der
bundestagswahlkampf wird wir wissen aber
auch nicht wie diese bundestagswahl
ausgehen wird ich halte das alles noch
für sehr unvorhersehbar da sind noch so
viele unsicherheiten unbekannte in
diesem wahlkampf drin das wäre das glaub
ich noch nicht wissen und auch die
koalition am ende oder zumindest
diejenigen die dann miteinander
verhandeln das können wir heute noch
nicht sagen und davon hängt natürlich
auch viel abwehr kann mit dem sehr gut
wo sind welche eigenschaften gefragt
also ich glaube da gibt das kann man so
in der sache noch nicht vorhersehen da
bräuchte ich jetzt mit google aber die
beiden haben natürlich das schon
aufgezählt für was die die beiden
kandidaten stehen einmaligen armin
laschet der auch in nrw ja schon gezeigt
hat dass er sehr integrativ sein kann
der sich in nrw vor der landtagswahl
damals schon ein team zusammengestellt
hat denn dass er unter anderem baustein
post auch mit eingebunden hat der ja
überhaupt nicht für seine richtung stand
und dann die wahl dann tatsächlich gegen
hannelore kraft noch gewonnen hat und
auf der anderen seite markus söder der
muss man auch sagen vor der landtagswahl
in bayern der unbeliebteste der
ministerpräsident in deutschland war und
dann einen aufstieg hingelegt hat den
glaube ich so mancher parteifreund nicht
gedacht hätte also der schon auch die
fähigkeit hat bevölkerung auch
mitzunehmen der viele ideen hat von
denen mancher auch gar nicht umgesetzt
werden am ende des tages also mancher
parteifreund spricht ob ich von zehn
ideen am tag und den am ende gar nicht
so viel übrig bleibt er hat glaube ich
ein manko er ist kein großer teamplayer
also er ist der der am ende der sagt
zwar spielt im team aber der am ende
vorne strahlen und das ist die frage
möchte man das möchte man sich kann man
sich hinter so ein versammeln jetzt
haben sie gesagt haben keine glaskugel
der balkon und das jetzt noch
schon jetzt erkennen könnte aber
vielleicht hat er ja eine dabei das
gehört ja auch zu ihrem job was erwartet
die bevölkerung eigentlich von einem
regierungschef oder von einer
regierungschefin welche eigenschaften
sollten dass sein
da hat ja angela merkel ein ganz klares
profil über die letzten jahre gezeigt
auch einen ganz bestimmten politikstil
haben die leute das jetzt überdrüssig
ist jemand wie soll da der das mal
anders macht braucht man da neue besen
kehren gut ja wie soll das dann was
erwartet die bevölkerung von einem
kanzler kanzlerin
das war ganz spannend zu sehen wie der
übergang von schröder auf merkel verlief
schröder der typ der basta typ der eben
entschied der vorne stand immer zeigte
dass er
der koch ist und andere in die kellner
rolle drängte die abwahl schröders und
zwar dann eine abwahl hat auch irgendwo
deutlich gemacht ist dieser politikstil
damals nicht unbedingt der war den die
bürger erwarteten der pragmatische
abwägende auch immer auch kompromiss
ausgerichtete stil merkels war mit
sicherheit der stil der zu der damaligen
zeit absolut passte die allerdings jetzt
so ein bisschen haben das gefühl eine
grenze kommt in einer zeit in der wir
eine krise stecken wohl eben
entscheidungen gefordert werden
führungsstärke gefordert ist in der
korona krise nach angesichts all der
dinge die dann nach der krise auf uns
zukommen ob das die wirtschaftlichen
sozialen finanziellen folgen sind oder
eben an die schwächen die sich in der
krise gezeigt haben die deutschland doch
auszeichnen eben in der bildungspolitik
in der gesundheitsvorsorge in der
digitalisierung das sind alles dinge die
die wahl als solches deshalb so
schwierig machen weil wir tatsächlich
nicht so ganz genau wissen was da alles
zusammenkommt die in welcher
prioritätenliste daneben welches thema
dann steht aber eins ist klar wird eine
situation sein wo wir hoffentlich gerade
aus dieser pandemie herauskommen - dem
gröbsten heraus sind aber wo dann eine
ganze reihe von zentralen aufgaben auf
uns zukommt und dann denke ich ist eben
schon zurzeit zumindest aus sicht der
bürger jemand gefordert der eben zu
führen in der lage ist er eben auch
gerade diese
komplizierten entscheidungsabläufe wie
sie sich im grunde gleich merkt ja
ausgleichen
es wird immer eine koalition geben kann
ich meinen persönlichen führung stehen
meine ich jetzt eine koalition erfordert
immer eine gewisse einen gewissen
ausgleich also das wird auch entweder
sollte erst in jemandes werden nicht
erspart bleiben dass er eben auch
kompromisse eingeht dass er eben auch
gemeinschaftlich führen und natürlich
auch so wieder brauchte auch die kleine
csu braucht die große cdu natürlich im
wahlkampf hinter sich also insofern ohne
diese geschlossenheit geht's überhaupt
nicht weder für den einen noch für den
andern er von marschall 1 kollege hat
heute in der fraktionssitzung gesagt wir
hätten ja sozusagen eine luxussituation
zwei sehr gute zur kanzlerschaft
befähigt kandidaten aber ist das nicht
genau das problem denn sie sind in ihrem
in ihrer persönlichkeit auch in ihrem
politikstil möglicherweise auch in ihren
inhalten doch ziemlich unterschiedlich
ist das dann wirklich so dass wir da das
sie da zwei befähigte haben und dann hat
man die wahl zwischen zwei völlig
unterschiedlichen personen belastet dass
nicht die partei oder die parteien also
nach meinem eindruck können wir das
gemeinsam gut nach vorne bringen wenn
wir so wie dies ja die beiden
parteivorsitzenden selber auch gesagt
haben letzten endes dann auch die
entscheidung akzeptieren mittragen und
dann den wahlkampf gemeinsam führen
ich will vielleicht nochmal zu markus
söder was sagen was was hat mich da noch
bewogen
ich glaube er hat zwei punkte sehr sehr
klar gemacht und auf die wird es
ankommen insofern will ich erstmal nicht
von koalitionen sprechen sondern erstmal
würde ich davon sprechen dass die union
gemeinsam gewinnen muss und was haben
wir dafür eine situation wir haben einen
gegner und das ist die afd
und ich habe erlebt wie markus söder in
aller schärfe und aller deutlichkeit
diese partei entlarvt als das was sie
ist nämlich eine rechtsradikale
und das ist etwas was auch dazu
beigetragen hat dass er sehr viel
zustimmung auch in den östlichen
bundesländern gefunden hat da ist
nämlich der gegner im aller ernstesten
szene die afd
jetzt schauen wir mal in den süden oder
in den südwesten nach baden württemberg
da ist der politische wettbewerber in
erster linie das sind die grünen
und ich glaube auch dort können wir von
markus söder lernen weil ich weiß dass
er mit großer entschiedenheit dieses
vielleicht ganz überragende langfristige
und entscheidende vielleicht überlebens
thema nämlich den klimaschutz besonders
ernst nimmt und das hat es auch beherzt
angehen wird
beherzt nicht nur technokratisch aber
beherzt mit der überzeugung dass wir
dass die union das besser kam dass wir
die besseren technologischen lösungen
haben dass wir da rein investieren
wollen das macht bayern ja jetzt schon
auch mit unterstützung durch
digitalisierung mit initiativen zur
wasserstoff technologie also auch mit
dem anspruch in diesen clean tech
bereichen wie sie heute genannt werden
weltmarktführerschaft zu haben und
insofern glaube ich hat er genau die
beiden richtigen themen erkannt auf die
es in diesem wahlkampf ankommen wird und
deswegen bekommt er auch so viel
zustimmung
herr polenz ich mir gleich noch auf die
inhalte eingehen oder mögliche
inhaltliche unterschiede aber gerne noch
mal einen moment bei den
persönlichkeitsprofilen der beiden
bleiben
ist das ein problem für cdu und csu dass
man vielleicht sagen könnte leider ist
der bessere kanzler kandidat aber
laschet möglicherweise der bessere
kanzler
es ist jedenfalls so dass sie sich beide
unterscheiden und dass die unterschiede
glaube ich auch schon ganz gut
herausgearbeitet worden sind
führungsstärke in dem kabinett was
natürlich ein koalitionskabinett sein
wird bedeutet schon vor allen dingen die
fähigkeit auch den anderen
koalitionspartner
die anderen koalitionspartner
mitzunehmen und da ist eben die csu sie
kann glücklich sein darüber eigentlich
nie so trainiert denn entweder als sie
alleine regiert oder jetzt mit den
freien wählern und ehrlich gesagt da
will ich ihnen nicht zu nahe treten im
freien wählern da sind die grünen oder
auch die fdp schon ein anderes kaliber
mit dem man dann klar kommen muss
also von daher ist führungsstärke in
einer regierung die fähigkeit zur
integration zum zusammenführen und man
erreicht das natürlich nur dadurch dass
man selber die ziele vorgibt visionäre
ideen hat und das alles versucht eine
flasche zu entwickeln in der überschuss
beispielsweise wir müssen die klimaziele
erreichen aber eben als industrieland
und ohne gefährdung unseres wohlstand
ist jedenfalls in der weise dass wir
dann zwar alle anders aber eben nicht
schlechter was jetzt geht jetzt in den
äußerungen um die dass das zusammenspiel
von ökonomie und ökologie vielleicht
sogar um das versöhnung von ökonomie und
ökologie
wenn man davon ausgeht das ist ja eine
koalition mit den grünen union grüne
nicht unwahrscheinlich ist mit welchem
der beiden cdu möglicherweise kanzler
oder spitzenkandidaten oder
kanzlerkandidaten könnten denn die
grünen klarer kommen in ihr wie könnten
sie ihr politisches profil starke
betonung von klima und umweltschutz am
besten umsetzen er mit söder ist söder
der modernere auch aus sicht der grünen
oder laschet ich glaube tatsächlich wenn
es um gemeinsames vorangehen geht glaube
ich wäre söder der einfachere partner
für die grünen weil wieder da doch
glaube ich näher bei denen ist als es
armin laschet es armin laschet ist nrw
ist ein kohleland armin laschet ist er
eher näher bei der industrie armin
laschet hat eben als es um den
kohlekompromiss ging auch eben stark
verhandelt was ihm auch die
ost-bundesländer übrigens anrechnen
sachsen nach wie vor
also da glaube ich wird es für die
grünen härter mit einem armin laschet
als erst mit einem markus söder wird
herr hilmer markus söder hat heute in
der fraktionssitzung die ente gesagt die
wichtigste frage ist für ihn wollen wir
gewinnen
das ist eine erstaunliche frage für den
vertreter einer partei die gemeinsam mit
der cdu
ein großteil der letzten 71 jahre in
deutschland regiert hat vielleicht kann
die frage anders stellen liege wittmann
eigentlich wahlen was gehört daneben der
person noch dazu wir haben jetzt gerade
über die inhaltlichen akzente auch die
verbindung zwischen person und inhalt
gesprochen was muss da sein dass man
wahlen gewinnt also ich finde die frage
durchaus berechtigt wollen wir gewinnen
denn man hat schon so ein bisschen das
gefühl dass die union stück weit noch
davon ausgeht dass sie eigentlich immer
als stärkste partei aus wahlen
hervorgeht und das ohne sie nichts geht
das war immer die maxime auch von angela
merkel und das hat sie ja auch immer
ziemlich perfekt hinbekommen aber wir
haben eine völlig neue situation
wir haben gesehen dass die union in den
letzten drei jahren ein unglaubliches
auf und ab erlebt hat sie stürzte wird
erstmal die bundestagswahlen noch
einigermaßen glücklich gewonnener
stärkste partei hat also diesen anspruch
erhalten stürzte dann allerdings in
dieser auseinandersetzung um die
migrationsfrage zwischen cdu und csu in
ein unheimliches loch wie man das kaum
mehr für möglich gehalten hätte hat sich
dann über die pandemie dann wieder
sprunghaft erholt weil sie eben auf
einmal wieder kreativer
entscheidungsfreude kommunikativ auch
gerade merkel auch merkel hat wieder
viel vertrauen zurückgewonnen die union
stieg wieder in richtung 40 prozent das
nahmen dann langsam ab weil die zweite
welle bei weitem nicht so erfolgreich
verlief wie die erste welle und ist
jetzt zusammen natürlich mit der maske
affäre dann wieder auf dem
ausgangspunkte von
zum zeitpunkt des rücktritts von von
kramp karrenbauer um die 26 27 und da
ist man dann irgendwann mal schon sehr
in gefahr das ist wirklich ziemlich
kritisch wird zumal die parteibindung
als solches die nimmt kontinuierlich ab
und einer krise ist das noch mal doppelt
wichtig wie man eben die krise selbst
bewältigt hat welche erfahrungen die
bürger dann mit den
führungspersönlichkeiten namen und vor
allen dingen wie personen sind eben
enorm wichtig das haben die beiden
landtagswahlen wieder gezeigt er wo eben
die amtierenden ministerpräsidenten
gewählt worden weil man ihnen vertraute
das geht diesmal nicht merkel tritt
nicht mehr an es gibt einen neuen
kandidaten einen neuen bundeskanzler in
jedem fall oder vielleicht auch eine
bundeskanzlerin und das ist für die
bundesbürger eine völlig neue
konstellation sie sind frei in ihrer
entscheidung und das ist für die cdu
erst einmal eine ziemliche bedrohung
denn sie kann deutlich zurückfallen sie
muss nicht mehr unbedingt stärkste
partei werden
in nordrhein westfalen die jüngste
sonntagsfrage hat gezeigt cdu und grüne
sind gerade noch mal zwei punkte
voneinander entfernt das ist ein
menetekel insofern kann man nur hoffen
dass sozusagen diese auseinandersetzung
die jetzt um die kanzlerkandidatur
erfolgte dass die wirklich einen weckruf
dann auch bedeutet und das ist der union
insgesamt ein bisschen deutlicher weg es
geht hier um sehr viel es geht um ihre
führungsposition in der bundesdeutschen
politik und es geht darum ob sozusagen
noch die letzte traditionelle
volkspartei als solche dann auch
erhalten wird und da braucht man eben
auch sicher eine person die eben in der
lage ist weit zu wirken und wählerinnen
und wähler anzusprechen ich glaube ich
schon gerade was die afg anbetrifft da
die union zuletzt enorm verloren in den
westlichen bundesländern ist es der
hauptkonkurrent dass das wetter gewisse
vorteile hat herr polenz wenn ja dann
würde ich gerne etwas zu sagen also herr
söder hat ja sagen der strategie
gegenüber dfd erst nach der landtagswahl
verändert wo die cdu offiziell ist nur
ihr lager fast zehn prozent eingebüßt
hatte
in nordrhein westfalen ist die afg nie
besonders stark gewesen ich bin ganz
stolz drauf
in münster hat sie nicht mal die fünf
prozent hürde geschafft bei der letzten
bundestagswahl
und ich halte es für ganz falsch
ein wahlkampf jetzt darauf auszurichten
dass wir möglicherweise wählerinnen oder
wähler von der afg zurückgewinnen für
jeden den wir dadurch einen
rechtsschwenk erreichen würden verlieren
wir drei in der mitte und deshalb halte
ich sehr viel von einem klaren kurs der
politischen mitte ohne so große
ausschläge die wir sie eben bei hanse
durchaus jahr registrieren konnte ich
bin ja froh dass er seine meinung zur
flüchtlingspolitik zu angela merkel zu
all diesen punkten geändert hat das war
ja eine große voraussetzung auch dafür
dass er jetzt diese umfragewerte hat
ohne diese ich sage mal fast 180 grad
wende stimmte er ja heute auch ganz
anders dar
laschet hat diesen kurs aus eigener
überzeugung die ganze zeit über
mitgetragen hat mit diesem kurs in der
flüchtlingskrise eine wahl gegen die spd
im größten bundesland gewonnen und er
weiß wie wir ja alle denke ich dass die
nächste wahl eine ganz ganz große
herausforderung ist und das ist
natürlich keineswegs ausgemacht dass die
union auch wieder stärksten fraktionen
wird und dass wir den kanzler stellen
können das weiß denke ich in der union
jeder jede gut jetzt ist die frage wie
kann die union die stärkste partei
wieder werden und damit auch den kanzler
stellen sei denn es kommt zu einer
koalition ohne die union dafür gibt es
ja auch konstellation her von marschall
wenn sich jetzt armin laschet durchsetzt
als kanzlerkandidat also markus söder
zur seite tritt
was bedeutet das für sie persönlich für
ihren für ihre arbeit für den wahlkampf
im wahlkreis in freiburg sind auch die
grünen durch ziemlich stark was bedeutet
dass sie gibt es ist das für sie ein 1
ein rückschlag ist es ein menetekel ein
ein großes problem jetzt
bundestagswahlkampf dann mit dem
spitzenkandidaten armin laschet zu
führen
na ja also ich sitze hier weil ich
markus söder unterstütze und gleichwohl
auch das in erinnerung gerufen habe ich
wenngleich im zweiten wahlgang im ersten
wahlgang hatte ich norbert röttgen
unterstützt
armin laschet zum vorsitzenden der cdu
deutschlands gewählt und deswegen stehe
ich natürlich auch loyal zu ihm und an
seiner seite und wenn er kanzlerkandidat
wird dann werde ich ihnen nach besten
kräften unterstützen und würde natürlich
auch hoffen dass er uns hier im
südwesten unterstützt aber was ich
eingangs sagte bleibt gleichwohl
zutreffend die menschen insbesondere
auch die aus unserer parteibasis mit
denen ich hier gesprochen habe die
würden sich eben wünschen dass markus
söder käme damit will ich aber auch
verknüpfen dass ich hoffe dass wenn es
armin laschet werden würde
kanzlerkandidat markus söder gleichwohl
eine herausragend wichtige rolle auch im
wahlkampf spielen würde und dass er dann
auch zu dem steht was er was umgekehrt
auch armin laschet gesagt hat nämlich
dass wir gemeinsam diesen erfolg wollen
und ich glaube dann kann das auch auf
diesem wege gelingen also auch dann wenn
armin laschet kanzlerkandidat werden
sollte herr polenz sie waren ja kurze
zeit auch generalsekretär der cdu sie
kennen die partei sehr gut wenn jetzt
markus söder kanzlerkandidat würde was
würde das für die cdu für die teile der
cdu bedeuten die eigentlich nicht als
kanzlerkandidaten haben wollten die also
sagen das ist eigentlich eine sache von
armin laschet gewesen jetzt müssen wir
da sozusagen klein beigeben wird es da
zu reibungsverlusten in der cdu kommen
mit der csu und wird sich das
möglicherweise auch negativ auf den
wahlkampf auswirken
ich glaube das kommt zum einen erst mal
sehr darauf an in welchem verfahren am
ende
söder nominiert würden im moment ist der
eindruck schon ein bisschen der nachdem
wir so der richtigerweise gesagt hat er
kann nur kandidieren
der will nur kandidieren wenn er die
breite unterstützung aus der cdu
dafür hat und am nächsten tag als dann
der cdu
das vorstand sich für armin laschet
ausgesprochen hat sagt also das hätte er
so nicht gemeint haben meint ihr
irgendwelche anderen teile der cdu das
war schon etwas schwierig zu verdauen
denke ich und jetzt ihre frage war ja
wenn erst dann wird ich glaube
entscheidend wird sein dass es ein
verfahren wäre dem dann auch die cdu
pflichtet und sagt okay wenn er aus
diesem verfahren gremium was ich bildet
beide parteivorstände tagen oder wie
immer oder die beiden einigen sich als
derjenige hervorgeht wer nominiert wird
dann wird ihnen die union sicherlich
auch die cdu ganz mittragen das würde
sie im zweifel sonst auch aber dann wäre
im zweiten fall wenn man das gefühl
hätte er hat sich hier nur mit
ellenbogen durchsetzen können dann gäbe
es doch ein gewisses zähneknirschen bei
dem ein oder weil er anfangs das würde
ich dann schon vermuten jetzt sagt man
immer markus söder hat einen vorteil er
kann mit beiden entscheidungen besser
leben als armin laschet
wenn das wird wird das und dann wird man
muss als ich in der bundestagswahl
bewähren wenn nicht kann er ja sagen ich
habe ihm ein angebot gemacht und wollten
das nicht und jetzt macht es eben der
andere ist dieser psychologische vorteil
spielt ja jetzt bei der entscheidung
noch eine rolle
ja ich glaube schon dass markus söder da
entspannter in diese entscheidung gehen
kann das hat man glaube ich heute auch
so ein bisschen gemerkt ich war bei der
fraktionssitzung natürlich nicht dabei
aber das was man raus gehört hat dass
ich schon das gefühl hatte dass markus
söder einen etwas selbstbewussteren
entspannteren auftritt hingelegt hat als
dass armin laschet getan hat der ja
schon jetzt deutlich kämpfen muss also
allein schon die tatsache dass er einen
gegenkandidaten hat zeigt ja doch ein
stück weit seine schwäche und
möglicherweise auch eine schwäche der
cdu und für ihn könnte es halt auch
schwierig werden wenn dann tatsächlich
markus söder kanzlerkandidat wird er ist
frisch gewählter parteivorsitzender der
cdu
er hat sicher auch gedacht er wird
kanzlerkandidat und er kriegt dann
dieses mandat nicht das schwächt ihn
wahnsinnig ist dann die frage muss er
dann möglicherweise sogar wieder als
parteivorsitzender gehen und tritt dann
die cdu im schlimmsten fall in einen
prozess einen der aussieht wie
bei der spd dass man einen vorsitzenden
nach dem nächsten verschleiß also das
sind schon solche gefahren und ich
glaube das zeitfenster ist jetzt sehr
eng da eine entscheidung herbeizuführen
die auch gut ist so dass man am ende
alle mitnimmt
das wiederholt sich geschichte nicht
unbedingt oder wie heißt es so schön
wenn dann als farce aber auf diesen
letzten gedanken mit der spd diesen
vergleich komme ich gleich noch mal
zurück herr hemer es geht ja auch um die
art wie man sich in der öffentlichkeit
präsentiert die ganze signale die optik
die kommunikation die verbale die
nonverbale wird ja immer wichtiger in
einer mediendemokratie
was macht das mit einem kandidaten oder
kandidatin kandidaten in dem moment noch
armin laschet wenn er auf dem spiegel
titel diese woche erscheint als
häuptling wird so nix als strauchelnde
also nach der vorlage der gallier
asterix vorlage ein strauchelnder
häuptling also parteivorsitzender dass
ich kaum auf dem schild halten kann wenn
jemand so in der öffentlichkeit
vorgeführt wird gerade in dieser
situation sie haben ja gerade auch schon
gesagt in welcher art und weise im
moment die umfragen zu ihnen schlecht
und für sehr gut laufen war das
sozusagen der senat in seiner kandidatur
ich muss gestehen dass ich fand er hat
das recht gut weggesteckt hat der
relativ souverän danach reagiert und so
ein stück weit hat man manchmal das
gefühl er erweckt auch so ein bisschen
an dieser auseinandersetzung mit söder
und entwickelte großes stehvermögen
haben ja also das kommt jetzt zum teil
schon zur geltung das kann natürlich
dann würde er sich dann immer auch im
endeffekt herren durchsetzen
für ihn bedeuten dass er wirklich mit
einem neuen image zumindest angedeutet
rauskommt und sich dann tatsächlich
seien zurzeit eben etwas problematisches
image ist eben einer der sich nicht so
recht entscheiden kann der laviert dass
er dies umsetzen kann zu einer
wirklichen tag
kandidatur dann zu einem sehr
entschlossenen und auch mitreißenden
kanzlerkandidaten also das will ich gar
nicht ausschließen
die die letzte phase wird in jedem fall
eine ganz andere sein als die in die wir
in der wir jetzt stecken und insofern
gibt es da schon möglichkeiten er muss
ja auch am ende nicht gegen köhler
antreten sondern eben gegen hp oder
berbalk und scholz und da sind die
chancen für ihn zumindest auch wenn man
jetzt nur das persönliche sieht deutlich
besser
da spielt er sozusagen in derselben liga
und er kann durchaus gestärkt aus dieser
auseinandersetzung dann auch hervorgehen
dass ich gar nicht ausschließen jetzt
hat die fraktionsgemeinschaft von cdu
und csu ihr eine lange geschichte
da erinnert man sich an 1976 den sondern
im kreuther beschluss sei wolle die csu
schon mal diese fraktionsgemeinschaft
aufkündigen
es gab in den letzten jahren
zusammenhang mit der migrationspolitik
sie haben ja schon erwähnt auch eine
reihe von bitteren konflikten ganz kurz
vor bruch dieser fraktionsgemeinschaft
den man sich jetzt die letzten wochen
mal an sie da hat man hoch und heilig
versprochen wir werden das gemeinsam
machen wir werden das untereinander
ausmachen dass da wird keine
verletzungen geben und dann werden wir
das gemeinsam vor die öffentlichkeit
treten und sagen wir genau
also wir haben nicht habemus papam aber
zumindestens einen kanzlerkandidaten und
jetzt entsteht eine konnte in den
wenigen tagen fast stunden eine solche
konfliktträchtige situationen dass man
sich ja eigentlich fragen muss passen
cdu und csu als parteien wirklich so gut
zusammen dass sie in einer
fraktionsgemeinschaft in einer
kanzlerkandidaten gemeinschaft in
zukunft erfolg haben werden
ich glaube dass dieser bruch der
fraktion jetzt nicht im moment bevor
steht also das glaube ich so weit sind
wir noch nicht da müsste schon noch viel
passieren und sie haben das erwähnt dass
es da eine lange historische geschichte
gibt und diesen streit 2018 haben ja
viele der jetzt beteiligten auch noch
miterlebt und da haben viele darüber
gesagt wir haben in den abgrund geblickt
wir haben gesehen dass ist
möglicherweise eine trennung und was
dass wir unsere parteien bedeuten könnte
und dann ist es tatsächlich auch muss
sagen die grosse arbeit von markus söder
und annegret kramp karrenbauer gewesen
diese beiden parteien wieder
zusammenzuführen also zwischen die
beiden hat ja kein blatt papier passt
und diese gemeinschaft glaube ich steht
nach wie vor also cdu und csu wissen sie
brauchen einander die cdu braucht die
kleine schwester um die entsprechenden
mehrheiten im bundestag zu haben und
auch umgekehrt und die cdu braucht auch
die kleine schwester um eben
möglicherweise konservativere teile
abzudecken sozialpolitik stark
abzudecken dass alles was die cdu/csu
mitbringt und die cdu bringt auch was
mit für die csu also man bedingt sich
sozusagen gegenseitig es ist jetzt doch
das habe ich auch gott schon gesagt
trotzdem die gefahr dass da schon auch
nochmal schäden entstehen in diesem
bislang ganz guten verhältnis und da
muss markus söder aufpassen dann muss
auch armin laschet jetzt eben aufpassen
dass es da nicht zu schäden kommt die
dann eben im wahlkampf dann nicht
zuträglich sind und nur probleme für die
beiden parteien bringen
marshall die auseinandersetzung zwischen
laschet und söder die bude im moment so
ein bisschen an wie ein boxkampf 15 die
runde die beiden kontrahenten sind schon
ziemlich erschöpft da hat man gehen dazu
über sich so aneinander zu klammern
wie kann diese blockade jetzt bis
freitag gelöst werden was muss da
passieren aus ihrer sicht dass es dann
tatsächlich erstens einen kandidaten
gibt und zweitens der verlierer sein
gesicht verliert und drittens die beiden
parteien und die fraktionen sozusagen
miteinander die friedenspfeife rauchen
also via die gesamtfraktion vertraut
durchaus nach dieser langen sitzung
heute darauf dass die beiden
parteivorsitzenden gemeinsam zu einem
ergebnis kommen
das ist unsere unser wunsch und unser
wille
ich will aber dazu sagen dass wenn wir
dann hoffentlich zum ende der woche ein
ergebnis bekommen dass wir auch
transparenz über das zustandekommen
dieses ergebnisses erwarten werden
gestern am tag vor der immer dienstags
stattfinden fraktionssitzung der
gesamtfraktion haben ja die
landesgruppen also die cdu und csu
abgeordneten aus ihren landesverbänden
eben getagt und dort ist es sehr
lebendig zugegangen wir haben sehr sehr
offene aussprache stattgefunden und die
vorsitzenden dieser landesgruppen die
haben glaube ich einen ganz wichtigen
auftrag die haben nämlich den auftrag
dieses stimmungsbild was in den
landesgruppen deutlich geworden ist an
die das parteipräsidium zu
transportieren und zwar in aller
aufrichtigkeit und auch in aller
differenziertheit und darüber kann ich
ja nur was baden württemberg nur was die
cdu-abgeordneten baden württemberg
betrifft sprechen aber das muss
sozusagen diese gesamtschau ist
zusammenfließen sozusagen beim
parteipräsidium der cdu und auch der csu
und ich glaube dass dann aus diesem
gesamtbild eine richtige
schlussfolgerung gezogen werden muss und
ich will vielleicht noch einmal in
erinnerung rufen dass armin laschet ja
selber mehrfach und zu recht gesagt hat
kanzlerkandidat der union soll derjenige
werden der die besten chancen für ganz
deutschland hat und ich glaube dass
müssen diese beiden männer in aller
verantwortung für unser land zusammen
aufrichtig und unter einbeziehung aller
stimmungsbilder die dort
zusammengetragen werden dann entscheiden
und wenn die erläuterungen zu dieser
entscheidung deutlich klar und
transparent sind dann werden wir sie
auch gemeinsam mit herr polenz am
freitag soll weißer rauch aufsteigen
über laschet und söder
wer soll nachgeben oder muss nachgeben
ich glaube die kunst würde darin
bestehen eine lösung zu finden die beide
als ein gewinn
insofern verstehen können als er die
union insgesamt voranbringt das ist
etwas schwierig im augenblick ist das
ganze so ein bisschen wie ein
nullsummenspiel ausgezogen aber als
union sind wir schon darauf angewiesen
dass es letztlich zu einer win win
situation wird und deshalb müssen beide
auch bereit sein aufeinander zuzugehen
wenn es so einfach wäre dass man sagen
könnte die besten wahl schlangen sowie
herr von matt er das gerade gesagt hat
hat derjenige der in den umfragen vorne
liegt dann könnten wir ja leicht in eine
satzung schreiben kanzlerkandidat wird
es weisen der der in den umfragen führt
pumpt dann hätten sie sich heute die
fraktionssitzung sparen können und wir
uns wahrscheinlich auch die phoenix
rolle
das ist nicht so einfach ist zeigt die
lange sie heute diskutiert haben und wie
lange wir jetzt schon diskutieren
das wird wahrscheinlich auch noch die
nächsten tage anhalten
ja immer ganz kurzer blick noch was kann
wenn es nicht zu einer win win sondern
sondern lose lose situation kommt also
wenn da zwei verlierer praktisch raus
kommen kann läuft die union dann die
gefahr den weg der spd zugehen die sich
ja auch in einem langen und
selbstzerfleischung prozess nach
politischen misserfolgen fast
aufgerieben hat bisher war die union ja
immer taktisch sehr versiert
machtbewusst
auch von einer gewissen raffinesse ist
das ein gefährliches vorbild für die
union
also man sollte zumindest daraus den
schluss ziehen dass volkspartei zu sein
kein merkmal ist dass man auf ewige
behält dann dass es immer wieder
verteidigt werden muss und das kommt
darauf an ob man mit den richtigen
ideen programmen an die wähler
herantritt aber es kommt halt auch ein
bisschen darauf an und zwar heute immer
mehr das eben auch die richtigen
personen für diese programme stehen und
vor allen dingen für die zuversicht dass
sie diese programme danach umsetzen
können ganz kurz zuvor am berger am
schluss wenn die kandidatenkür und dann
der wahlkampf schiefgehen kann die union
eine richtige krise geraten
na ja das was der film auch gerade
gesagt hat also dass die union den
status der volkspartei hat ist nicht
gottgegeben und sollte das tatsächlich
alles schief gehen dann kam dieser
status weiterhin gefährdet sein und dann
rutscht die cdu möglicherweise die ganze
union möglicherweise eben auch in einer
solchen krise abwehr sie die spd jetzt
auch schon erlebt gut das werden wir in
den nächsten fünfeinhalb monaten genau
beobachten ich bedanke mich bei
katharina hamberger bei richard hilmer
bei ruprecht polenz und bei mattern von
marschall liebe zuschauer morgen in der
phoenix runde ausgangssperre und
testpflicht was bringt merkels notbremse
jetzt folgt phoenix der tag mit thomas
bade auch da geht es um diese corona
notbremse die wurde ja heute im kabinett
verabschiedet gleitet sich hochoffiziell
ja in den namen infektionsschutzgesetz
bleiben es bei uns